بنزيما في جده واستعدادات الاحتفال شغال
هو محافظين العالم يلجاون الى تويتر
للتعبير عن ارائهم واخرهم الاعلامي الشهير
كارلسن وقصه فنانه سعوديه شابه ترسم
الاصوات اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
اللاعب الفرنسي كريم بنزيما اللاعب نادي
الاتحاد السعودي اقلع من مدريد الى جده
صباح اليوم استعدادا لحفل استقباله اللي
راح يقام على ملعب الملك عبد الله الجوهره
بكره من بعد ما تمت مراسم التوقيع على عقد
بينه وبين نادي الاتحاد يوم الاثنين
لثلاثه مواسم الحماس مال المنصات من وقت
ما نشر النادي صوره بنزيما طالع الطياره
ومن بعدها نشر بنزيما نفسه صورته في
الطياره وكتب عليها هيرويجو مع علم
السعوديه الحفل بكره راح يكون مجاني
لجماهير الاتحاد وراح يكون موجود 60 الف
مشجع بينهم رابطه الاقتراحة الاتحاد وراح
يكون في شعل الناريه في الملعب للترحيب
بنزيما وراح ينقل على قنوات النادي
الرسميه ومن نصف ساعه كمان نشر النادي
رابط التقديم على تذاكر حفل استقبال
بنزيما طيب خلينا
وامس كان خلينا نقول انه امس كان نشر
النادي بيان عن ضم بنزيما واعتبروا الصفقه
من اكبر الانتقالات شهره وتاثيرا في نشر
او تاريخ النادي وتضاف للخطوات التاريخيه
لرحله الدوري السعودي للمحترفين اللي
بيعزز من مكانته كوجهه لافضل اللاعبين
بالعالم طيب اما بنزيما فقال انه متحمس
لخوض تجربه جديده في بلد جديد وقال انه
نادي الاتحاد عنده تاريخ مذهل ومشجعين
حماسيين وطموحات كبيره وانه هو دائما كان
بيشعر بحفاوه الاستقبال في السعوديه وراح
يعمل بمساعده زملائه في النادي لنقل
الاتحاد لمستويات وافاق جديده وقال كمان
انه على علم بقوه الدوري السعودي وخاصه
بعد قدوم نجوم مثل كريستيانو رونالدو وقال
انه اهدافه بالفوز ما راح تختلف عن لما
كان في اوروبا بعدها شفنا بايو بنزيما على
تويتر تغير وصار وصفه اللاعب كره القدم في
نادي الاتحاد وكان كشف رئيس نادي الاتحاد
انوار الحائلي في البيان عن رقم قميص
بنزيما رقمه مع الاتحاد راح يكون تسعه مثل
ما كان مع الريال وعبر عن سعادته الكبيره
بالتعاقد معه ونشر من بعدها النادي فيديو
من لحظات توقيع العقد
انا متحمس اشوفكم في جده
وحقيقه من امس وحساب نادي الاتحاد برحب
ببنزيما على طريقه او طرقه الخاصه ومن بين
صوره لرباط يد بنزيما وقت ما كان يحطوا
بسبب اصبعه المكسور واللي كان رافض يعمل
اللي يعمل له اي عمليه علشان ما يتغيب عن
صفوف نادي السابق ريال مدريد لاشهر النادي
نشر صوره لرباط يد بنزيما وعلق عليها
الاحلام تنتزع وبنزيما رد على الصوت وكتب
ضجه على المنصات في تونس بسبب ظاهره غريبه
رصدوها الناس في الضواحي الجنوبيه للعاصمه
التونسيه وهي التغير لون مياه البحر الى
الاخضر
يا ناس هي ذابح حرحب بوجاردين
اخضر ولا عينيا معناه
في البحر
[موسيقى]
بحر اخضر اخضر هذيك اخذ
ت الله اعلم
الفيديو اللي شفتيه متداول بشكل كبير جدا
على المنصات والناس بتقول انه السبب في
تغير لون البحر للاخضر والروائح الكريهه
اللي جايه منه هو التلوث اللي من فتره
بتشهده شواطئ المنطقه اللي تحولت لمصب
لمياه الصرف الصحي ومو صالحه للسباحه
واعتبروا موت السلحفاه البحريه اللي
موجوده على الشاطئ دليل جديد على التلوث
البيئي وتلوث مياه البحر والاتهامات هذه
ردت عليها وزاره الفلاحه والصيد البحري
بانه في فريق راح من الوزاره على المكان
وعمل معاينه واخذوا عينه من مياه البحر
والوزاره اطمنت ان التلوث مو السبب في
الوزاره قالت انه التحاليل المجهريه بينت
ان السبب في تحول مياه البحر للون الاخضر
هو تكاثر هائل للطحالب الدقيقه اللي
معروفه باسم ازهار العوالق النباتيه وهي
غير سامه وقال البيان انه هذه الظاهره
طبيعيه وبتصير عشان تغني البيئه البحريه
بالمغذيات واسباب تزايد التكاثر الطحالب
بيكون زياده درجات الحراره والاحتباس
الحراري احنا عملنا بحثنا وطلع فعلا في
ظاهره مثل كده في العالم وفي مسطحات مائيه
كثيره تم رصد تحول مياهها للون الاخضر
بسبب الطحالب وفي بعض الاحيان بتكون طحالب
ضاره
[موسيقى]
المحافظين حول العالم واللي بيعانوا بحثا
عن منصات لعرض ارائهم يبدو انهم لقوا في
تويتر الملجا فمن بعد ما تولج اللي بيهاجم
ثقافه
بتسعه للمساواه الى ثقافه بتروج لاجنده
اليسار المتطرف اليوم شفنا عوده ذكر
كارلسون من بوابه تويتر من اشهر
الاعلاميين الامريكيين المحافظين وهو
الاعلى اجرا وتصنيفا في وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه وكان ذكر طرد من فوكس نيوز من
شهر تقريبا وبشكل مفاجئ وهو اللي من سنوات
كان بيطل فيها ببرنامج ساخر وبيعرض من
خلاله اراءه الكثار بيعتبروها يمينيه
ومحافظه متطرفه ذكر امس طال في اولى حلقات
برنامج تويتر واتكلم فيه عن تفجير سد نوفا
كخوفكا في اوراق اوكرانيا وعن الاجسام
الطائره وتجاهل وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
لها وهاجم الرئيس الاوكراني
زيلنسكي ووقف الى جانب روسيا وكعاده ذكر
الحلقه مكسره الدنيا فحتى اللحظه هذه اللي
بكلمكم فيها والحلقه عليها اكثر من 68
مليون مشاهده واكثر من 161 الف رتويت وفي
نهايه الحلقه ابتكر وضح سبب اختياره
التويتر للعوده من خلاله
[موسيقى]
وعلى فكره ذكر كان من الشهر الماضي نشر
اعلان انه راجع على تويتر وقال في اعلانو
وقتها انه تويتر صار المنصه العالميه
الوحيده اليوم اللي فيها حريه تعبير
واو
ان يقفز يسيرا
اكثر من مره بتحويل تويتر لمنصه لعرض كل
الاراء يبدو من اكثر المبسوطين برجعه
الذكر فعمل ريتويت للحلقه هذا اولا وعلق
عليها وقال انه من الرائع ان يكون هناك
برامج من كل الاطياف السياسيه على هذه
المنصه
بعد حوالي ثمان ساعات على مدار يومين
انتهت شهاده الامير هاري التاريخيه امام
المحكمه العليا في لندن في الدعوه لرافعها
هو وتسعه وتسعين مشهور اخر على شركه ام جي
ان الاعلاميه اللي بتصدر
صحفهم الشركه انها اخترقت هواتفهم ونشرت
معلومات عنهم حصلت عليها بطرق غير قانونيه
امس كان الامير هاري خلال شهادته اتكلم عن
تاثير الصحافه الصفراء في حياته انه هو
طول عمره كان بيشعر انه يعني انه الصحافه
بتنتهك خصوصيته انه الصحافه الصفراء
مضايقته وتطفلها كان انه له دور كبير في
تخليه عن واجباته الملكيه وتكلم كمان
الامير هاري عن دور الصحافه في حياه
والدته الراحله الاميره ديانا في الجزء
الثاني من الشهاده اليوم وكما كان متوقعا
شاهدت وجابت سيره افراد العيله المالكه
والكلام اليوم كان على اخوه اللي مو اول
مره هاري بيهاجمه او بيجيب بالتصريحات
خلينا نقول انها مو ايجابيه يعني هاني
اليوم في المحكمه قال عن اخوه الامير
ويليام اللي هو امير ويلز وولي عهد
بريطانيا قال انه اندفع له مليون جنيه
استرليني في 2020 مقابل اسقاط قضيه كان
رافعها ضد وسيله اعلام اخترقت هاتفه وعلى
فكره هذه مو اول مره هاري بيتكلم عن هذه
التسويه السنه الماضيه وفي قضيه اخرى جاب
سيرتها ايضا لكن اليوم ولاول مره ذكر
المبلغ مليون باوند خلال الجلسه اليوم
الحوار بين الامير ومحامي الشركه كان
محتدم وان سمع المحامي وهو بيقول للامير
انا هنا علشان اسالك مو انت تسالني كان
مفاجئ في جلسه اليوم كمان رد الامير لمن
سال لو عنده ادله على ادعاءاته باختراق
هاتفه فقال انه ما عنده لكن اللي كان ينشر
او اللي كان ينشر كان كلام مسجل برسائل
صوتيه على تلفونه وما في طريقه ثانيه
ينعرف فيها وقال انه هو رفع الدعوه علشان
يثبت تعرضه للاختراق في ختام شهاده الامير
سالوا محامي عن احساسه وهو بيمر بكل اللي
صار امام كل اعلام العالم من بعد كده
لحظات صمت تردها للتاثر بانه كان احساس
صعب
بالحديث عن الامير هاري والقضايا فهذه
القضيه في بريطانيا مو الوحيده المتعلقه
بالامير واللي بينظر فيها اليوم في العالم
فعلى بعد الاف الكيلود مترات وفي امريكا
مكان اقامته تنظر محكمه امريكيه اليوم في
دعوه رفعتها جمعيه محافظه بالطالب انها
تعرف كيف حصل الامير على تاشيره لدخول
البلاد وهو معترف من قبل اكثر من مره انه
اخذ مخدرات طبعا اشهر واكثر مره تكلم في
الموضوع كان في كتابه وعلى فكره اصلا معظم
الاشياء اللي قالها في المحاكمه وبيتحدث
لاحقا عنها انها غير مريحه بالنسبه للحديث
عنها مذكوره في كتابه في سبير على العموم
خلينا نقول انه نكمل مع بعض انه طالبت
المؤسسات الحكوميه بالكشف كيف حصل الامير
على التاشيره وطالبت كمان بالاطلاع على
الاستبيان اللي ملقوا الامير اللي يدخل
البلاد واللي فيه سؤال عما اذا كان الشخص
سبق وضعت المخدرات او لا
[موسيقى]
نجود العتيبي فنانه سعوديه شابه بترسم من
لمن كان عمرها ثلاث سنوات واليوم صارت
نجود اول فنانه وامراه خلينا نقول وسعوديه
بتنضم لبرنامج اقامه دريفن في استوديو 13
في دبي لدعم وتعزيز مسيرتها المهنيه
الاقامه هذه هي احدث مراحل المبادره اللي
هدفها دعم المواهب الصاعده في الشرق
الاوسط
الى جانب
الى جانب هذه المشاركه نجود لها قصه رائعه
وملهمه حقيقه مع الفن الفنانه الشابه
بتعاني من ضعف السمع لكنها قدرت تستغل هذه
العقبه وتحولها لمصدر الهام في فنها وصارت
تستخدم هذه العقبه في الرسم
وترسم الاصوات زي ما سمعتوا بالضبط بترسم
اصوات كيف ومن فين جاتها الفكره وفي كمان
غيرها من الاسئله احنا في تفاعلكم مستغلين
وجود وجود في دبي وقابلناها عشان نسمع
قصتها منها شخصيا فانا اترككم مع هذه
المقابله واعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله
في الخميس الونيس اجمل ايام الاسبوع في
امان الله
يا اهلا يا نجود كيف حالك الحمد لله كيف
حالك الحمد لله انا تمام خلينا نبتدي من
المعرض قبل ما نرجع نتكلم عن الفن ودخولك
للفن والكلام هذا كله بس كلميني عن اخر
معرض
انه الافتتاحيه للمعرض في لقامه الفنيه
اللي هي معين وانا اعتبر اول فنانه اكون
فيه واول فنانه سعوديه اول فنانه كامراه
مثل مره جميل خلينا نرجع شويه لوراء واصلا
انت كيف دخلتي هذا العالم الارت الفن
هي القصه تضحك لانه انا بدات عمري 3 سنين
وانا صغيره بيبي لانه اكتشف بابا يرسم كنت
اقول يعني وانا لين دحين فاكره هذا الموقف
اقول كيف يحول البحر على اللوحه كيف كيف
بنقولها اوكي صوره كامله فكنت اشوف احركها
بالفرشه عرفتي فبعدها تعلم وهو صار يعلمني
حتى كان يقول لي انه انت الوحيده اللي
تتعلمي ما حد ما حد من اخواني كان يتعلم
بس بعدها صرت ارسم صرت حتى كمان ماما تقول
لي صرت ارسم خالاتي لما يجي ارسمهم وارسم
تفاصيل اللي انا شايفاها زي الاحد شعري
منكوش ولا اللي عنده بطنها
يعني
بس بعدين لما صار عمري خمس سنين
اصبت بالضغط السمع بس اهلي ما عرفوا انه
ما برات الاعراض عرفتي بس لما
جاكي كان عرض من اعراض اخر مرض الحمى اللي
دمج الاطفال
فما حد كان يعني انت ما حد كان شايف انه
ايش المشكله بس بعدين لما صرت في الثانوي
اه عرفوه وصاروا ينتبهوا انه انا صرت حتى
اسمي ما اسمع لهم الا لو احد دقن عرفت
انتبه
فهنا وقتها صرت لن ارسم فصرت قلت اخترت
الرسم الهايبر اللي هو الرسم الواقعي الفن
الواقعي فهذا الفن انه انت بيتك لتشوفي
الصور وتنقليها على
تكون التفاصيل يعني بالتفصيل الممل يعني
وياخد شهور اخد ايام
فاي احد لما يشوف الرسمه يقول لك كيف
سويتيه وكيف قعدتي ايام فانا وقتها انا لو
اقول لك انا كنت احس انه منعزل عن نفسي مو
انه من عسلي عن العالم عرفتي وكنت احس انه
انا عالقه في مكان واحد فاذا انت طورتي من
نفسك مره كتير في موضوع الرسم وجربت الطرق
مختلفه واشياء مختلفه وكده بس يمكن واحده
من الاشياء اللي لفتتني اللي هي قصه انك
انت بتقولي انك انت بتنقل الاصوات
بصراحه غريب يعني هو اللي خلاني انتقم
بهذا الشيء لانه انا كنت ما كنت اعرف اعبر
عن مشاعري في الرسم
عارفه اللي
كل الفنانين يعبروا عن نفسهم ايش هو نفسهم
انه انت مين كيف عيشتي وانا كنت ناكره هذا
الشيء عرفتي انه انا كنت ناكره انه لا انا
ما عندي ضعف سما انه هذا الشيء حيتغير
ممكن حيتزبط ممكن حتعالج انه كنت ناكره
نفسي
بالضبط فيعني حتى اوقات كنت استحي دايما
انزل شعري لما البس السماعات عرفت
مرتاحه بس انا من جوا ماني مرتاحه عرفتي
فانا قررت
لازم نعبر عن نفسي لازم اطلع للعالم سواء
يعني مو شرط انه اتكلم لا انه على الاقل
حتى من خلال شغلي عرفتي
فغيرت انه اقرر الستايل حقي خليته الفن
التجريدي بس مره كنت سهل فمره رحت البحر
مع صحباتي
دايما لما انزل البحر بس السماعات وده مع
صاحباتي نتكلم صحبات قالوا لي انت كيف
تسمعينها مره واضح وانت لا يعني اضحك
عليهم
جد يعني من جد سامعه كل شيء مضبوط فسويت
بحث عن هذا الشيء وقتها دخلت
مسكين وسويت بحثي عن الاصوات فاكتشفت انه
الاصوات بحر كبير يعني دحين احنا في
الغرفه هذا في الغرفه هذه هم مصممين
الغرفه هذا عشان الصوت يوصلك
ويوصل بس ما يوصل لبره عارفه مصممين
الصاله كبيره انه الصوت يوصل لبعيد على
حسب المسافه
البحر لما تتكلمي ما في ما في جدار ينخبط
عرفتي البحر يعني الصوت لما تتكلم الصوت
يروح ويجيكي على طول يعني ما في حواجز
حتى كمان يقول لك زمان الناس اللي في
الصحراء كان اسمه من بعيد انه
فكل هذا اخذتيه وبدات انك بتعبر عنه في
اللغه بالضبط طيب وبعدين يعني انت ايش
بتحاولي توصلي من هذا كله لو قلت لك مثلا
قشري صالتك في هذا الموضوع ايش بحاول اوصل
اول شيء انه المتعبر عن نفسك لما تتقبلي
نفسك مو سهل كل الناس لما تشوف الكوتس
والاشياء هذه بيرسل
موضوع مره صعب صحيح
بس خصوصا لما يكون عندك شيء وكلنا كلنا
مختلفين ما احنا زي بعض بس اختلافاتنا هذه
هي اللي تميزنا
ولازم يعني يعني انا مختلفه مو انه انا
خلقته للمختلفه عشان اكون احسن منك ولا
شيء لا انا عشان اشجعك عشان ادعمك عشان
تشوفي انه اه هي قدرت تسوي كده انا اقدر
اسوي كذا انا لما اشوف فنانين وصلوا لهذه
المرحله انا يعني
هموني عرفتي مو بس كمان فنانين رسامين اي
احد يعني عنده طباخ ممكن يكون يمر بظروف
صعبه هذا الشيء مره يهمني
ههه يعطيني حل
الموضوع وتقبلتي الموضوع
مره كنت صعب انه اطلع للعالم اقول لهم انه
انا كذا قبلوني طيب أنا
عرفتي
فهو هو هو لما قدمت انا في مسك وقلت لهم
قصتي انا
توقعتبين فيني عرفتي اللي اللي تحس الناس
عندهم عطش القصص هذه
اوكي طيب والان المستقبل ان شاء الله
المستقبل ايش ناويين شوفي للحين افكر انه
ان شاء الله هدفي هدفي الوحيد انه زي ما
لهبت نفسي ان شاء الله الهم غيري خصوصا
الناس
اللي عندهم صعوبات تعلم او صعوبات زي في
السمع او عندهم او ذوي الهمم فان شاء الله
يعني اكون انا مصدر الهام لهم هذا الشيء
اللي انا اطمح له صراحه وما
لا وخصوصا كمان يمكن انه في حراك فني كبير
كمان في السعوديه
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله يكون جزء منه ان
شاء الله يعني يوم من الايام بتشوفوا
اعمالي منتشره في السعوديه تكونوا تشوفوا
كمان
مره شكرا لك
[موسيقى]